welcome back while the media is busy
celebrating those texas democrats who
are fleeing their responsibilities
the president and his handlers are hard
at work using this stunt to push their
national agenda
the for the people act also known as hr1
a bill that would rewrite election laws
nationwide
assuring that democrats always win
they're doing this right out in the open
just like our last guest who said i
don't believe in voter id
completely unchecked so where are the
republican leaders who are elected to
stop them what are they up to
today we face a threat america has never
seen before
a former president who provoked a
violent attack
on this capital in an effort to steal
the election
why didn't the president call the guard
where was kevin what what conversations
did kevin have what members were
involved
if you're not vaccinated you're part of
the problem rather than part of the
solution
right now 12 plus can be vaccinated to
be safe in the schools get vaccinated
i believe it's time for us to address
the here and now as well as
the international effort we're going to
have over some decades
to try and reduce our co2 emissions
joining us now is the great one mark
levin he's the host of life liberty and
levin
on this network and author of the
fantastic smash
new book american marxism out today you
can get it today
and you should if they still have them
because i know he's had mountains of
pre-orders mark congratulations on the
book we're going to get to that in a
moment because it's more than a book
it's a movement
and you've talked about that but first
when you hear that clip
from capitol hill to covid to climate
with friends like this considering what
we're up against
no wonder we're on the verge of american
marxism
yeah there's no question about it you
know we the people are going to have to
take
action ourselves we cannot rely on the
list cheney's the romneys or the others
of the world
they're like out of the 1950s republican
party they don't understand what's
swirling around our country today
joe biden and his party are playing for
keeps they're trying to destroy our
voting system have you noticed pete
that they never show us all these voters
who have been denied the right to vote
are all these lawsuits brought under the
voting rights act in 1965 where you have
a
cause of action if somebody has
prevented you from voting because of
your race or sex
or what have you have you noticed all
the cameras from cnn and nbc and abc
in these communities showing us all the
people who have been denied the right to
vote
this is a big lie and the democrats work
on big lies
all the time the fact of the matter is
we want as many people to vote as
possible
if you're allowed to vote the rule isn't
everybody votes anybody votes whenever
they want to vote wherever they vote
that's not the rule that's never been a
rule
that's chaos that's anarchy that's
california
we don't want to californianize the rest
of the country
the democrat party is about the democrat
party not the country
everything they're doing now is about
empowering the democrat party
they want to destroy the court system
they want to pack the senate they want
to pack the supreme court
they want to eliminate the uh the
filibuster rule the borders are wide
open to help the democrat party down the
road with votes that's their intention
that's what they're about party before
country and you know what else pete
have you noticed that pasaki and biden
and the other democrats
never talk about what's in their bills
what's in their bills they want 16 and
17 year olds
to register to vote they want people to
be able to vote in any precinct in the
state no not the precinct they're in
they want no signature match they didn't
want any voting id until about two weeks
ago when they realized that even their
base believes in voter id
i could go on and on for the people act
this is the corrupt
act of course we know they want to pass
it so that later on we can find out
what's in it and of course in the
meantime they're characterizing it
as the most critical threat to our
democracy which they always
mischaracterize
since the civil war mark now you you
write about history you understand the
constitution with these kinds of
characterizations
uh do they really believe it or is this
just how they go along
getting what they want
these are demagogues these are
propagandists they all
say exactly the same thing and they say
it with passion and they say it with
emotion
regardless they are liars this isn't a
for the people act this is a for the
democrat party act
you know critical race theory says view
everything through race
view everything through the eyes of
control of the democrat party it has
that in common with a lot of these
autocratic parties all over the world
party for
look what's going on in cuba it's about
the party keeping control
in north korea he doesn't care about the
people or the country it's the party
it's the communist party
gee it's empowering the communist party
venezuela
empowering the communist party the
democrat party whether it likes it or
not has a lot in common with this
mindset
it's all about the democratic party
they're not progressives they're not
democratic socialists
they're not the liberals they are in
many ways
our american marxist movement so mark
real quick we've got about a minute
uh you say this book is more than a book
it is a movement
why well because
this book does things i haven't done
before this book has scholarship which i
explained
it's got a lot of substance which i
explained it's the longest book i've
ever written and at the end it's about
activism why
because as i've said earlier we are not
at the precipice looking
into the abyss we are in the abyss and
we need to claw our way out so whatever
little disputations we have among us
whether you're libertarian or moderate
democrat
if you love this country you have got to
get involved from our classrooms
to our borders to our constitution they
are all
under attack and the democrat party
means to change this country
and millions of us like me need to
protect this country
that's why this is a growing galvanizing
movement we need to rally around
around our founding principles one of
the things i love about mark is it gives
people specific things they can do
once they realize we are in the abyss as
you talked about and i got to believe
you never thought you would have to
write a book entitled
american marxism you're right it's
unbelievable
scary it says everything mark levin the
great one correct congratulations again
book is out today we're honored to have
him on fox news primetime
mark thank you so much hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else